E
IDENTITY THE WHITE HOUSE IS
CHOOSING NOT TO SHARE, MIKE.
>> Mike: PETER DOOCY UP THE
ROAD IN WILMINGTON, DELAWARE,
THANKS A LOT.
LET'S BRING IN SENIOR POLITICAL
ANALYST BRIT HUME, GOOD EVENING.
>> HI, MIKE.
>> Mike: WHAT IS YOUR
ASSESSMENT OF WHERE THINGS
STAND?
>> WELL, MUCH ABOUT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WOULD LIKE TO
TURN THE PAGE AWAY FROM THE
STORY, AND OTHER THINGS COME I
DON'T THINK THE STORY WILL LET
THEM DO THAT.
THE MEDIA DECIDES TO COMPLY AND
FOCUS LESS ON AFGHANISTAN THEN
DID SO INTENSELY FOR WEEKS.
BUT THE AFGHANISTAN IS LIKE A
TIME BOMB OVER THERE.
YOU HAVE THE SITUATION THAT IS
DESCRIBED AT MAZAR-E SHARIF
AIRPORT AND THE RENEWAL OF
TERRORIST ATTACKS EITHER ON THE
U.S. OR ITS ALLIES EMANATING
FROM AFGHANISTAN AND YOU'VE GOT
THE QUESTIONS UNDOUBTEDLY WILL
BE RAISED ABOUT A COUPLE OF
OTHER THINGS, MIKE.
ONE IS HOW DO WE GET THESE
PEOPLE OUT AND NOT GET OUR OWN
PEOPLE OUT?
WE NEEDED TO GET OUT AND WHO ARE
THESE PEOPLE THAT WE DID GET
OUT?
WERE THEY PROPERLY VETTED?
WHO ARE THEY?
AND THE QUESTION IS, DID ANY
TURN OUT TO BE ACTUAL
TERRORISTS?
THAT WILL RAISE QUESTIONS ANEW.
SO WE HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO ON
THE STORY, MIKE, BY THE
ADMINISTRATION WITH THAT THEY
LIKE IT OR NOT.
>> Mike: FOR THOSE WHO COPE
WITH THE WHITE HOUSE OVER THE
YEARS THE SENIOR OFFICIALS
SERVED AT THE PLEASURE OF THE
PRESIDENT MEANING YOU MIGHT BE
OUT OF THE JOB IF THAT IS WHAT
THE PRESIDENT NEEDS.
DO YOU THINK, SENIOR OFFICIALS
WILL BE OUSTED DUE TO THIS MESSY
WITHDRAWAL?
>> I THINK THE MESSY WITHDRAWAL
WAS LARGELY ON THE SHOULDERS OF
BIDEN HIMSELF.
EVERYTHING WE LEARN FROM THE
DECISIONS MADE AS TO BIDEN
WANTING OUT IN THE LAST THING WE
WOULD HAVE HIS KABUL AND THE
EMBASSY.
THAT MEANT THAT HAD TO BE CLOSED
BECAUSE WOULD NOT SERVE ANY MORE
TROOPS IN.
SO THIS IS OVERWHELMINGLY
LARGELY ON BIDEN.
BUT THEY CAN'T FIRE HIM.
AND IF THIS GETS WORSE FOR HIM
POLITICALLY, HE MIGHT FEEL THE
NEED TO GET RID OF SOME OF THESE
PEOPLE AND BE SEEN AS TURNING
OVER A NEW LEAF.
BUT SO FAR, HE HAS STUBBORNLY
CLUNG TO HIM AS PETER DOOCY JUST
REPORTED, TO INSISTENCE WITH
THIS WHOLE THINK THIS WAS A
GREAT SUCCESS.
I DON'T THINK THE PUBLIC AGREES.
I DON'T THINK IT WILL LIKELY
START TO AGREEING SOON.
>> Mike: WITH ALL OF THESE
AMERICANS AND AFGHAN PARTNER
STUCK IN THE COUNTRY, DO YOU
WORRY THIS COULD BE WORSE THAN
THE IRAN HOSTAGE CRISIS LAY IN
THE ERA?
>> SOME OF THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE AMERICANS AND OTHERS THAT WE
CARE ABOUT THAT ARE THERE TO BE
TAKEN AS HOSTAGES AND USED FOR
BARGAINING.
AND SOME THINK THAT MIGHT HAPPEN
WITH THOSE TRAPPED IN MAZAR-E
SHARIF.
BUT THAT REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
BUT IT IS CERTAINLY A
POSSIBILITY.
YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE IN ADDITION
TO HAVING THE TALIBAN IN CONTROL
AND THE UNITED STATES, YOU HAVE
THESE TERRORIST ELEMENTS THERE
AND AL QAEDA AND ISIS K THAT MAY
TURN OUT TO BE WILLING TO GRAB
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND AS WELL.
SO I'M GOING TO SAY, IT IS A
WORRY AS PART OF A TICKING TIME
BOMB.
>> Mike: BRIT, WE HAVE A FEW
SECONDS REMAINING.
DO YOU GET A SENSE
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S POLITICAL
ADVISORS WANT OUT OVER HIS
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISORS IN
THIS CASE?
>> I WOULDN'T SAY JUST POLITICAL
ADVISORS BUT JOE BIDEN IS A MAN
THROUGHOUT HIS LONG CAREER AS
NOT HAD A LOT OF FIXED
CONVICTIONS.
HE HAS BEEN A CREATURE OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND ITS CURRENT
OPINIONS.
IN THIS CASE, HOWEVER, HE
DEVELOPED A FIRM CONVICTION.
HE DIDN'T LIKE AFGHANISTAN FOR A
LONG TIME AND WANTED OUT.
AND I DON'T THINK IT WAS JUST
POLITICAL ADVISORS.
I THINK IT WAS HIM.
I THINK HIS MILITARY ADVISORS,
INDEED, OVERRULED.
APPARENTLY, THEY HAVEN'T FELT
STRONG ENOUGH TO QUIT BECAUSE
THEY ARE STI